Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at emotional intelligence.
Now, this is a really important human skill for life and business.
Much research has shown that just being smart is not enough.
As well as intelligence, you need emotional intelligence to work well with people.
Here are five steps to help you develop and build your emotional intelligence.
First, know your emotions.
Recognize how you're feeling in a business situation.
Separate your thoughts and judgments of others from your emotional response.
Second, manage your emotions.
Relaxation techniques, deep breathing,...
...keeping a journal where you can express any negative emotions.
These are all good ways to help you manage your own personal emotions.
Third, motivate yourself.
Think what kind of situations do you have negative emotions.
Maybe this kind of meeting or talking to this person.
Think how you can act and behave differently to avoid this.
Fourth, recognize others' emotions.
Try to understand how do other people feel in a given situation.
Look at their body language, facial expression,...
...as well as what they say to help understand how they feel.
And finally, manage relationships.
When working with people, don't just think about the business, numbers, and figures.
Think how can you keep good emotional relationship by recognizing their emotions and respecting them.
By showing understanding and working together.
So emotional intelligence, a very important skill for your business and life.
Good luck!